welcome everyone to what's going to be a
chess career update video and an
announcement video
um for those that don't know I'm
currently overseas in Europe
and actually a few days ago I posted a
photo it was basically a YouTube
Community post also an Instagram post uh
showing me in my location and asking
people to guess where I am and a few
people took this challenge way too
seriously and were able to pinpoint my
exact GPS coordinates but I am in beul
Switzerland and I'll be here for the
next two weeks for the Beale
International chess Festival
and I'm really looking forward to it
this event has been on my bucket list
for years now and uh my first time
playing and first time actually in
Switzerland as well
so I want to show the official website
and here we see
most of the tournament information
uh it's gonna be a 10 round Swiss format
uh I guess Swiss is not only the country
that we're playing in but also the
pairing system that's used and the cool
thing about this tournament is it's just
one game a day which I'm really not used
to playing like most of the other
tournaments I played in uh there's been
multiple rounds with two games a day
most recently in Vegas there were four
days in a row with two games a day and
uh if you watch any of my recaps from
that tournament I didn't really have
time to shave during the event so this
is going to be way more chill but
another thing about this tournament is
it's played with a Time control that
I've actually never played before it's
going to be one of the longest time
controls I've ever played in my life we
can see here it's gonna be a hundred
minutes for each side for the first 40
moves and then after move 40 there's an
additional 50 minutes added and then on
move 60 there's an additional 15 minutes
added and on top of that there's a 30
second increment throughout the game
so games can easily last like five six
seven hours uh no problem and when I
played in Vegas I had long games but the
long games were like four and a half
hours
so this is gonna be
probably a marathon event I'm hoping to
not have too many games that go over six
hours but I do have to be ready for it
and um yeah throughout the event I'll be
taking every game very seriously I'll be
preparing a lot and I also plan to do
daily Recaps for the YouTube channel so
um yeah earlier this year I've played I
think three different classical events
uh in February I played in Norway it was
a krogero tournament and then Iceland in
April and then Vegas in June so this is
my fourth classical Tournament of the
year if you want to watch my previous
Recaps from the uh the other tournaments
I played I'll leave links to the
playlists below but real quick I want to
show the player list for this tournament
uh we can see that there's a lot of
Grandmasters a lot of title players have
to scroll down to find my name I'm the
47th seed I think there's going to be a
big opportunity to play a lot of players
hopefully stronger than me if I do
really well there are opportunities for
uh Grandmaster Norm but as usual I'm not
gonna try and make that the the sole
goal I'm really just trying to enjoy
myself Play Good chess and keep keep
learning keep improving as a player
um I think that's uh that's what allows
me to bring out my my best chess
so um I don't want to make this video
too long but I do want to give people
kind of an overview of the event so do
stay tuned for my recap videos
throughout the tournament I will try and
post some daily and one more big
announcement uh the one and only
Jonathan schrantz is coming back to take
over my twitch Channel twitch.tv I am
Rosen linked below he's going to be
doing commentary for
um I think for most of my rounds
um there's no guarantee that my games
will be broadcast I have to do well
enough to get on the the boards that are
broadcast but when my game is broadcast
live do check out the twitch channel for
Jonathan taking over he took over in
Vegas and people really seem to enjoy it
so that that will be the place to watch
my games but also leave links to the
official website the official commentary
and then also the broadcast on chess.com
and leeches so a lot of ways to follow
the tournaments be sure to to stay tuned
and if you have questions or just want
to wish me luck leave a comment below
and I'll see you guys soon for the
Recaps